finally at this hour students at home
are keeping connected for halloween with
a virtual choir performance our very own
brian loftis shows us what's cool at
school
[Music]
students at home keeping connected for
halloween with a virtual choir
performance in what's cool at school
[Music]
late one night where my eyes beheld an
eerie sight a halloween tradition
continues
we always would put together a halloween
performance
and even with 2020 being the year it's
been silvestri junior high school choir
still pulled off their halloween
performance
virtually i wanted to be able to give my
students an opportunity
to where even though they weren't
necessarily singing together in the
classroom
they still were able to experience that
choral
part of being a part of something the
month-long process involved crash
courses on adobe
students filming two separate videos
with singing and choreography
teachers pulling sound files from
sopranos altos
mixing them together to create monster
mash
they did the monster match
it was a graveyard smash it was quite a
process to get that it made the hours
and hours of extra time just totally
worth it
for the choir family continuing their
halloween tradition during a pandemic
and the resulting distance learning
they've struggled through
was important maybe even necessary i
wanted them to
to feel like even though covet is going
on that we're still able to maintain
that sense of normalcy we can still
keep those traditions that are important
to to our school and to our choral
family
from his coffin tracks voice did ring
seems he was troubled by just one thing
all 40 students that took part lit up
when they saw their performance
the best part of the project was
definitely watching their faces when i
showed them the final outcome
[Music]
when you get those videos and you're
watching them and you're like oh
they really are singing behind that
microphone or that bitmoji figure or
whatever it is that they have on like
there really is a kid there
and that's what's cool at school home
edition
if you know something that's cool at
school during these days of distance
learning
let us know about it send us an email
cool at school at 8newsnow.com
denise that was the song we needed
during ted's weather yes we did
that's a classic that's a that's a
teacher really going
outside the box and i love that story i
know
it's a really good one well done brian